[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here samsung had
their foldy event today which means i
get to show you the phones that i got to
play with behind the scenes a little bit
before they came out which is as we
expected two folding phones so we've got
the galaxy z fold three with a better
cover screen more durable folding glass
s pen support it's got an under display
selfie camera i made an entire separate
hands-on video with this phone it'll be
the first thing to hold that like button
definitely check it out it's really nice
but then also there's this guy the z
flip three and while honestly this feels
like a less surprising pretty modest
update comparably of all the folding
phones this is actually the one that i
feel like i'm most likely to start
recommending to regular people they've
made a lot of good calls here so the
z-flip and z-flip 5g have been out for a
little bit what were people asking for
from a new flipping phone
so a better bigger cover screen
a high fresh rate main screen
and lower the price a little bit
okay
check
check
and kind of check so let's just start
with the price the flip 3 is going to
start at 9.99 which is its lowest ever
price it's the lowest price of any of
their folding phones uh but the baseline
version of it now has 128 gigs of
storage where the previous flips all had
higher prices but they all started at
256. so they've made a lower priced
version
thus having a lowest ever price but you
can see how they've sort of turned that
narrative a little bit i still think 999
is pretty clutch though because while it
is definitely still expensive it's now
in line with some other regular flagship
smartphones people are going to be
considering buying it just happens to be
the one that's folding in half so i'm
happy to see this lower price but the
inside screen the folding display which
is still the same size and aspect ratio
is also now 120 hertz which is great
everything is now benefiting from being
super smooth and you can always turn
that down to 60 hertz if you want to
literally feels like the iphone will be
the last flagship to go higher fresh
rate but that's the conversation for
another day and all of this is wrapped
in a design refresh that includes a
larger and more functional cover display
going from that tiny 1.1 inch screen
from before to a 1.9 inch cover screen
now it's not quite the huge 2.7 inch
screen on the razer but this is a much
bigger window and it makes a huge
difference so by default it's still just
going to be showing you the time which
is the same as before cool plus you get
the battery and the date
but now swiping over to those different
widgets and quick actions is way more
functional and comfortable now it's not
that tiny postage stamp size screen
you've got music controls alarms timers
and they're now an actually usable size
and so this is the stuff you don't
always want to have to open the phone to
get to but the most important thing is
notifications so if you swipe to the
left of the time you get all the
notifications on your phone and yes you
can read more than one and you can
actually swipe to dismiss individual
notifications and you can actually
manage them properly from the outside
display that is beautiful so you can of
course dive into the settings and
customize a little more of what happens
on this outside screen samsung's built a
bunch of neat time animations so if you
want a little more color or if you want
to keep it clean or maybe you want
multiple clocks for different time zones
there's a lot to play with here and then
you can even add or subtract widgets you
don't use so i know i'd probably add in
the weather widget and the calendar for
myself and you can reorder them
all of that is great and you always know
what to expect when you swipe
so overall that's a pretty big usability
improvement for the outside screen on
the flip of course it can still be your
camera viewfinder when taking photos
with the primary dual cameras it still
shows you the phone number the name of
whoever's calling you all that good
stuff is still here just
bigger and i don't know about you but
i'm kind of liking this new dual tone
design honestly if you didn't have any
logos on it like if you just told a
younger version of me that this was a
folding pixel i probably would have
believed you it kind of looks like the
aesthetic from that panda pixel 2
but the sides are a little bit flatter
too which definitely helps with
modernizing it a bit and it feels good
in the hand plus the new hinge is
improved again and it's improved to the
point where the whole phone is now ipx8
water resistant which is pretty sweet uh
that means you can dunk the phone in
water drop it in a puddle or spill
something on it momentarily and it'll be
fine which is cool now ipx8 does not
mean
dust resistant unfortunately the stuff
that usually ends up plaguing folding
phones like the grit and stuff that gets
in the hinge can still make it through
there so it's not certified to block
that stuff out but it's cool to see a
watertight seal but also they tossed in
some better speakers this time so the
original flips just had this one not
that great speaker at the bottom and the
earpiece now flip 3 actually gets a much
improved speaker in the same spot and
there are dolby atmos stereo speakers
now so new gorilla glass invictus on the
back
same fingerprint reader on the power
button this is nice this is a nice
package this is a really nice folding
phone design in 2021 now this doesn't go
as far into the high end as the fold
three so it doesn't have s pen support
even though it does have 30 stronger
screen protector on the inside folding
glass and it also doesn't have the under
display selfie camera it still has the
hole punch but as far as the most
reasonable folding phone put together so
far in 2021
i mean this one i think this one takes
the crown it has the flagship specs
snapdragon 8 and 8 gigs of ram it has
flagship cameras a standard and an ultra
wide the battery is the same size as
last year so that could be the only
concern now that we just got high
refresh rate but then putting this all
in nicely designed water resistant
refresh at 9.99 to me this has serious
potential and even if this doesn't turn
out to be the one that a lot of people
start buying the trajectory is pretty
good of getting down that price and
making it as close to a regular phone as
possible but all that being said i still
have to test this phone i'm going to be
reviewing it very soon so make sure you
subscribe to see that if you haven't
already and of course check out the fold
three because you might be into that
bigger more high end more interesting
look again it's the link below but
either way that's been it catch you guys
the next one
peace